qu'ovide oblige les visiteurs ont
déserté depuis des mois les jardins du
château de villandry seul un drôle de
moustiques survole ce joyau de la
renaissance
perché à 90 mètres de hauteur ce drone
est équipé de caméras et de capteurs de
pointe
le photographe du jour c'est lui voilà
non je refais à chaque fois il fait une
photo à bon en fait il va être en
capacité de faire ce rappel de la
photogrammétrie donc en fait il est là
pour prendre des photos à une succession
de photos avec du recouvrement sur
chaque photo est le but c'est de recréer
une grande photo du site ainsi qu'un
modèle 3d une haute technologie au
secours des vieilles pierres jardin et
bâtiments seront entièrement numérisé 7
autres appareils
c'est un scanner qui passe au crible la
façade avec son rayon laser ou part
d'une coque de déjà d'un édifice de
coexistence et c'est évident pour le
coup on doit d'abord comment dire
appréhender sa géométrie de manière la
plus la plus précise possible
c'est pour ça qu'on utilise les scanners
et les drones et une fois qu'on a
appréhendé la géométrie et ben on va
chercher à être le plus fidèle possible
par la modélisation une modélisation 3d
au centimètre près c'est un outil
précieux pour la future rénovation de la
façade centrale va pouvoir sortir
immédiatement des dessins des façades
jeu j'aurai je pourrais répertorier les
réseaux d'eau les réseaux laiteries dans
le château
chaque petit chantier ben je connaîtrai
également est exactement les surfaces
des pièces et des murs et des plafonds
c'est tout un ensemble de données comme
ça qui sont contenus dans cette maquette
qui vont m'être très utile estimé à près
de 500 mille euros
ces travaux de restauration devraient
débuter en 2022